the penn center has found out that the
NSA surveillance is driving writers to
self-censor so this isn't just that
we're spying on writers but just the
idea of fear has stopped writers from
writing about things and has stopped the
investigative reports that Unleashed
this whole thing in the first place
let's look at the study's findings
eighty-five percent of surveyed writers
are worried about government
surveillance of americans seventy-three
percent have never been as worried about
privacy rights and freedom of the press
as they are today sixteen percent of
writers have avoided writing or speaking
about certain topics due to threatening
privacy concerns eleven percent are
seriously considering avoiding certain
topics so that that's the part that I
want to start about first just the
general fear that this thing has created
whether it's true or not or every week
we find out something else is new now
they're looking at your buddy lists and
now they're you know they're taking all
the information from your web browser
and all that but let's just talk about
the fear first is there nothing to fear
but fear itself you know you mean like
what what should if you were an
investigative journalist how do you
think you would you would deal with it
I'd like to see somebody go through the
process of what really happens when you
are flagged or when they're spying and
you not in a snowed-in type situation
because he has he took it upon himself
to release information but let's say
you're a journalist and you write about
something that is disturbing to
government members or possibly something
they find is private I want to see the
actual process because the way you take
away fear is you just show people what
happens there's this looming government
is spying on me keeping a file keeping
tabs in some you know thing that they're
gonna use against me later and even if I
get a parking ticket and they want to
say oh but we have this on you it's
going to be used against me tight fear
or maybe people are afraid they're going
to blow up your car in a parking lot I
mean the fear is real so we'd be
interesting to see what somebody goes to
in the process of when you know what
happens when they catalog your
information what happens when they're
watching you I don't know more but isn't
that something though just the way you
frame that that the fear is not just
that they're watching you and maybe
looking at your remotest but then the
next logical step if you don't have
faxes well then they could be listening
to me my car or bombing by like all
those crazy things which seem paranoid
but roll though I mean I got theory that
they want you to be afraid that they
keep leaking more information about how
much they're spying on you just in order
to keep everyone in line
they control us because we're fearing it
they can control us so I don't know if
there's any real ramifications but even
teasing the idea that somebody may have
been killed by the CIA because they
mentioned something government didn't
like people are like the CIA is covering
it up I'm like or did they plant that so
we live in fear I am completely with you
you took like six of my questions David
oh no that's perfect take it I don't
know I start I mean ah yes it's horrific
what's going on and yet uh I just don't
think the government is that organized
and that intelligent and can get their
[ __ ] together that amount I mean look at
the Obamacare they can't run a website
so should we trust right like can they
really compile all the information if
the NSA or the CIA wants to target you
and believes that you're you know a bad
guy or whatever of course they're gonna
build whatever they can but you know
this is a chilling effect this is this
is you know a huge chilling effect under
journalist I I get it and yet uh I I
like what you're saying I think we need
to to really be realistic about it what
you know what is the reality of it is
there's I mean I think corporations
shape what journalists do way more than
the government does and yet censorship
is is a real issue and and
self-censorship is it is it's it's
convenient for the government because I
can actually do less they don't have to
make laws against journalists like they
did in you know Eastern Europe or the
Soviet Union they can just you know
release this information but I don't
know I I tend to be not be the
conspiracy person yeah so I board up
while I'm on board a little bit of book
what you're boasting but I think in
terms of like the way that this stuff
keeps getting leaked every two weeks we
hear another bombshell now we're
listening to anglo Merkel's phone calls
just good but I we're good this is good
that we think that would you rather get
it all at once actually see that's why
sometimes i think that there's a little
collusion between the government and
Snowden because it's like in a weird way
if he has all this information why not
really so much now we're being a few
know that if you do it an all one story
people can't take in all that
information this way it keeps the story
alive it keeps his case alive it keeps
the case of the necessity of the
watchdog in government alive and that's
the real issue here is
how do we watch our government how do we
have some sort of overseeing of our
government and you know the watchdog
laws become completely undermined in
this country and Obama hasn't done
anything he's done nothing but is
prosecuted more writer more uh
journalists than any every other
president combined I mean that's a
frightening fact right there so but I I
think it's important that they leak it
out this way and and yet we have to be
responsible citizens and say okay this
isn't so much about fear but this is
about the reality and we have to do some
we have to elect the right people to
help us make the right legislation to
protect citizens from the government is
this gonna go down as Obama's like
biggest failure like forgetting
Obamacare and what everyone think about
foreign policy right now but this that
there's just this fundamental distrust
of government and it this read this all
happened even though a lot of it started
obviously with bush and patriarchal
epics this is happening on yes watch and
he's expanding executive hours now well
I think the combination of expanding
executive powers and also we have a
legislative branch that does only things
that they are funded to do directly by
people that are your in Congress Rory
nothing yeah you see can you talk about
you know other segments we were talking
about before we're talking about how
Congress now there's so many lobbyists
or basically buying their votes and
paying for things we have a combination
of corporations running your legislation
and your executive branch kind of doing
things still within the best interest of
Washington people start to get pissed
and then when people get past you have
people that start to not like their
government that's what you're saying
there's wealth confidence in government
less trust it's not necessarily just an
obama thing I think it's more access to
information I think its people getting
fed up I think its people the people
that were maybe more of Obama's biggest
supporters I think are also that same
people that tend to want progress
exactly people want to run on progress
and change don't want more of the same
old Washington so it's not surprising
when they're tired when Obama kind of
comes the last stop of oh man like we
trusted you we liked you right and now
you're just like every other politician
one of them and then you start to
realize every politicians been like
every other possible so the ocean
progressives feel because how we here at
the Young Turks with the type of things
we shouldn't we be the most annoyed at
him the average person in the middle a
hundred percent yeah absolutely and it
does it feels both the extremes of both
the parties because we you know both
extremes distrust him very much
and so yeah we should be disappointed
but you know I think the tactics are
important that we need to elect people
that we believe in that are our
progressive candidates we need to work
on more local level and and I keppel
can't write about those things because
journalism ready to write what your
candidates are doing and that's a
problem you know I am so sick and tired
of people talking about voting for the
lesser of two evils yeah if that is the
best we can do in this country right now
we have to do tomorrow sir but that's
democracy I never won any bit of parties
change parties evolve and if you're just
a lectin you know a Romney or and Obama
who basically essentially the same
person coded in a few different minor
policies then you know I see the again
it's kind of like people getting
dissolution going what's the point and
that's where the Tea Party came I mean
that that's absolutely how the Tea Party
was born because there was so much
disillusion with their own party that
they broke off and hopefully you know it
won't get to pitchforks and torches but
you know okay actually yeah I'm done
with that guys do not want chaos trust
me no no do not pitchforks that's not
gonna cause chaos pitchforks okay